all right we're gonna go through two
confrontations that took place over the
last few days they are very different in
nature i think there's there are some
important things to be said about both
um rand paul was confronted by a
kentucky
resident during a town hall that he did
we're gonna look at that a little bit
later but first i want to talk about
what happened to fox news propagandist
tucker carlson when he was at a
fishing store fish supply tackle bait
type store
you can tell i don't fish um in the
state of montana where he was confronted
and what i wanna
we're gonna look at the video we're
gonna look at the reporting but what i
really wanna focus in on here are two
things
one the reactions about the nature of
what took place here
from a speech standpoint that's number
one
and then number two the utter disgusting
dripping hypocrisy that comes uh with
this tactic which i've also i mean you
guys might remember i recently was also
confronted by someone who disagreed with
my political views in public so
let's get right into it huffington post
report
man confronts tucker carlson at montana
store
you were the worst human being when a
local
fly fishing guide spotted noted vaccine
skeptic tucker carlson at a sporting
goods store in livingston montana he did
not waste time
dan bailey can be heard telling the fox
news host in a video you were the worst
human being known to mankind
he captioned the video it's not every
day you get to tell someone they are the
worst person in the world
and really mean it what an a-hole
um there's one other interesting aspect
to this
which uh which i will get back to okay
so here's the video
if you're watching it's subtitled it's
only about 25 seconds long
i don't care man just dude
[Music]
settle down sun is very very
condescending
and tucker is an expert clearly in being
condescending
probably picked up those techniques at
his various country clubs
um from reports about how he treats the
staff at country clubs a little bit more
here
all right so tucker then walking away
and looking apparently at some
flies or bait or something like that now
here's one up before we get into this
here here's the most incredible part of
this entire story
the guy who confronts tucker carlson is
named dan bailey
the confrontation happened at dan
bailey's fly shop
but the dan bailey who did the
confrontation
has nothing to do with dan
bailey's fly shop it's a coincidence
that a guy named dan bailey in
livingston montana
is in dan bailey's shop and is not
actually the dan bailey from the shop
like it is this a common name
or something and it's an incredible
detail that just adds to
the entire insanity of it but okay so
what are the reactions i mean this was
speech right guys there was no physical
violence
if anything it was actually uh
tucker carlson who at different points
in time
is sort of getting very very close to
dan bailey and and getting up really
close to him if you could argue if
anybody was
physically intimidatory here uh it was
really more
tucker than anybody else so clearly
right wingers are in favor of the speech
right well not exactly
check out what dinesh d'souza said big
free speech advocate quote this is a
shocking video
this man should be arrested for what he
did
to tucker carlson in front of his
daughter first of all the moralizing
about in front of his daughter
i don't even know that i get that but
certainly it has no criminal relevance
but what would you arrest dan bailey for
that he expressed a view
that is different than that of dinesh
d'souza or different than that of tucker
carlson
or different than that of tucker
carlson's daughter maybe i mean who
knows what tucker carlson's daughter's
political views are
you are all about free speech and not
regulating and
all this different stuff and you want
someone arrested for something they said
when it was tucker who got real close to
the guy and actually started poking him
on the chest
what crime sir sir sure
yeah so this happened to me not that
long ago
okay i described the incident a little
while ago
um i was sitting outside at a terrace at
a restaurant
and as i was walking away i heard
someone go
hey pacman and i turned i was about 30
feet they watched me walk right by them
waited until i was 20 30 feet away then
said hey pacman i turn around
don't say anything just turn around and
they say
you jew imperialist bastard
change your ways and as i've said before
i'm not against the principle of the
this
technique um if you're a public person
and you're in public
people are going to come up and give you
their opinion and most of the time
people come up and they say hello and
they say they agree with my opinions it
just happened a few times this weekend
and every once in a while someone might
disagree this happened to be an ignorant
[ __ ] who was anti-semitic right
once they drop in you jew imperialist
bastard
but there's a different thing here it's
not
what i think about the technique what
does tucker himself think of the
technique well
tucker came out in favor of this
technique remember when tucker carlson
did
an entire segment on his show urging
viewers to accost
mask wearing strangers and parents of
children who are being told to wear a
mask tucker said
accost them on the street he encouraged
it
and so he must be okay with this
technique right well
according to the daily beast reporter
justin baragona
a fox news spokesperson said that the
man in montana
was ambushing tucker carlson in a store
and that it was quote totally
inexcusable
and that no public figures should be
accosted regardless of political
persuasion or beliefs
due to the intolerance of another point
of view so wait a second guys
tucker's view is parents who are not
public figures
they're just parents if they are wearing
masks or their kids are wearing masks
even though they're not wanting to be
public people they're not choosing to be
public people
they should be accosted per tucker
carlson but
tucker as one of the highest rated uh
hosts on fox news
who chooses to go out there and be a
public figure and say these things
he's off limits that's the point of view
between tucker and fox news it's
deranged guys it is
absolutely and completely deranged these
people are hypocrites
when you know the principles first
people
not only you know i've said before
principles first is not
always i mean okay talk about principles
but the difficulty is in applying the
principles to the real world
and if you only talk about principles
you lose reality that's one critique of
principles first
the other critique is a lot of the
principles first people abandon their
principles as soon as it's inconvenient
to what they
what they actually want to experience in
real life so absolutely pathetic
and disgusting and um uh this this is uh
this has happened to me
i've got to deal with it i could stop
doing my show i could wear a disguise i
could you know do whatever the hell i
want
um but uh the idea that this arrest this
man
is just the you know it's it's peak
cringe
giga cringe i think is what i would uh
call it in fact
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the
privacy app and the browser plug-in let
you give each company
a randomized virtual credit card number
that you create
out of thin air it'll even autofill the
card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them
you can delete them anytime you want so
when you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or
credit card info protected against data
breaches and identity theft
and it's free and like i said you'll get
five dollars to spend when you sign up
at
privacy.com pacman